évoqu mtenant on va évoquer ce qui s'est
passé dans ce lycée du Havre il y a
quelques jours un professeur a sorti un
couteau en plein cours et a menacé ses
élèves cette scène a créé la panique
chez les élèves mais selon les premiers
éléments le professeur n'aurait pas
voulu faire de mal à l'un de ses élèves
il aurait été submergé par l'émotion
après une succession de DRAM dans
l'actualité en particulier bien entendu
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard une
semaine plus tôt dans un instant Nicolas
glier professeur en colère sera avec
nous pour évoquer ce malaise ce malêtre
même qui exige chez de nombreux
professeurs et regardez ça ça a fait
énormément parler vous allez nous dire
ce que vous en pensez tiens euh de ça
c'est parti la scène surprenante et
inquiétante s'est déroulé devant une
trentaine d'élèves d'une classe de
Première un professeur d'histoire Geo a
sorti un couteau le procureur du Havre a
confirmé qu'une enquête a été ouverte
suite à un signalement du rectorat le
corps enseignant est également choqué et
rappelle le contexte actuel tendu après
l'attentat d'aras c'est évidemment
quelqu'un qui n'allait pas très bien
mais comme toute notre profession et ça
fait longtemps que plein de collègues ne
vont pas bien il ne se sent en général
pas très soutenu par par la hiérarchie
alors il y a des grandes déclarations en
ce moment mais le le quotidien des
collègues c'est pas ça c'est de se
sentir pas soutenu merci Nicolas glli
d'être avec nous c'est un plaisir de
vous avoir à chaque fois professeur de
lettrre j'ai envie de dire en colère
est-ce que c cet incident traduit un
mal-être chez les professeurs oui al
c'est Mo qu'on puisse dire ouiou
maintenant on nous assassine donc ça
change voilà c'est c'est pas mal alors
forcément on peut pas défendre ce
collègue dans l'absolu on on ne peut pas
sortir un couteau en cours on ne peut
pas en partie menacer des élèves qui
n'ont rien demandé qui n'ont rien fait
maintenant ça apparaît ça ça ressort à
une période où on vient d'assassiner
encore un collègue après Samuel Patti
euh il y a une crainte
les tous mes collègues ont peur on en a
parlé entre nous sur les cyos rouges on
en parle il y a une peur qui est là on a
peur de faire notre métier avant on on
on on gueulait contre nos conditions de
travail la maltraitance du ministère le
fait qu'on nous harcèle parfois qu'on
nous gère n'importe comment que des gens
soient placés dans des postes horribles
pour commencer ce qui est terrible le
fait qu'on soit mal payé peu reconnu par
le pays maintenant on se retrouve dans
un paradoxe total c'est que les ennemis
du savoir euh que sont les fanatiques de
tout bord sont les seuls à reconnaître
notre importance c'est assez génial
quand même c'est-à-dire que les seuls à
reconnaître qu'on est important ce sont
nos ennemis et ils viennent nous
assassiner pour nous montrer qu'on est
important génial j'adore cette
reconnaissance très inéressant c'est
très fort alors que le gouvernement ne
le sait pas et ne ne nous reconnaît plus
la population a oublié qu'on était
important et valorise parfois des
métiers qui sont moins importants pour
la société donc nous c'est toujours la
même chose qu'on qu'on porte c'est notre
slogan salaire moyen respect
respectez-nous parents d'élèves élèves
société et euh ne nous assassinez pas
tous les professeurs tous les
enseignants tous les instituteurs c'est
je vous dis c'est la base en fait c'est
la base si dans un pays euh tu as pas
une bonne éducation et tu as pas euh des
enseignants si tu as pas des
instituteurs si tu as pas des des des
professeurs euh le le pays peut pas
tenir c'est l'avenir du pays c'est eux
qui l'ont entre les mains donc c'est
peut-être un je dis c'est un pour moi
des trois métiers les plus important à
part bien sûr avec la santé aussi voilà
avec les pompiers voilà mais c'est un
des trois métiers les plus importants en
France et c'est vrai vous avez raison ce
qui est fou on fait les générations de
demain et justement face à nous on a des
gens qui ne veulent pas qu'on puisse les
créer les construire ces génération
demain mais si vous avez pas les moyens
de les construire aussi vous pouvez pas
faire des miracles on risque pas de le
faire mais justement on se retrouve avec
des collègues effrayés actuellement dont
certains qui pètent un câble on peut pas
dire autre chose qui pètte les plombs
alors ce collègue il est en arrêt je
crois bon je pense qu'il faut qu'il y
reste un certain temps mais il ne faut
pas laisser cette situation perdurer il
faut prendre en compte le fait que les
collègues sont très mal sont dans un
état psychologique fragile et ont peur
actuellement on travaille dans la peur
ch ce collègue alors raconte pour nos
téléspectateurs aussi c'est quoi le donc
il avait un cours d'histoire et puis à
un moment il a eu des phrases qui font
écho à ce que vous venez de dire d'un
coup il a sorti un couteau Marc Opinel
un petit couteau il l'a déplié et il a
dit j'en ai marre de perdre mon temps de
faire mon boulot pour lequel on
assassine voilà c'est un peu ce que vous
dites c'està-dire qu'il était à bout
après il a eu des phrases plus dures je
vais les citer quand même si on m'énerve
je suis capable de soulever une seconde
et de la frapper jusqu'à ce que sa tête
explose donc il était à bout il faut
préciser que il y a une chaîne de
réaction c'était une classe de Première
il y a une chaîne de réaction très
rapide les élèves la direction le
rectorat tout le monde la police tout le
monde est intervenu et la première élève
auditionnée a dit on a senti qu'il était
hyper énervé mais je ne me suis pas
senti menacé alors il y a une enquête
judiciaire pour violence avec usage aux
menaces d'une arme c'est vrai qu'il a
été vu par un médecin et pour le moment
voilà il est pas radié pas viré il se
repose et il était dans un état
psychologique en détresse on peut le
dire voilà Nicolas est-ce qu'il y a des
sujets que les profs évitent pour voilà
pour essayer de de de pas avoir de
problème ou bien sûr ah oui ah ben
évidemment mais il y a une enquête qui a
été faite il a la moitié des professeurs
qui se censurent en classe qui se
censurent en histoire en SVT en français
et il y a quelque chose que j'avais déjà
dit ici d'ailleurs c'est que euh
l'institution elle-même censure avant le
meurtre de Samuel pati 2011 sous la
droite au pouvoir 2014 sous la gauche au
pouvoir les mêmes inspecteurs avaient
cherché à faire interdire le 18e siècle
en histoire et en français pour ne pas
qu' ait de problème c'est devant devant
en fait un malaise devant la bronca que
les profs avaient fait en disant oui bon
faut peut-être arrêter de renoncer à ce
point-là aux lumières au savoir euh à la
critique des religions à leur étude
historique contextualisé et pas
théologique concrètement pas voilà il
faut pas renoncer et l'inspection a
tenté de le faire donc il y a des profs
qui renoncent il y a l'institution qui
renonce il y a une lâcheté généralisée
face au fondamentalisme notamment
islamiste et qui est présente dans
nombreux d'établissements notamment dans
des quartiers difficiles Pascal moi je
voulais vous poser une question moi je
me souviens c'était il y a pas si
longtemps quand on allait à l'école au
lycée au collège le professeur avait de
l'autorité il était respecté aujourd'hui
on a le sentiment que non seulement au
niveau salarial et ça c'est une chose
c'est vrai que vous n'êtes pas reconnu
que la grille
salariale européen exactement mais même
vous êtes bas par rapport aux autres
professeurs de l'Union européenne ça
c'est un fait ça c'est une chose vous
êtes mal payé et à partir de quand vous
avez senti la bascule c'est-à-dire que
l'autorité on a le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui l'autorité des
professeurs n'est plus respectée pour
alors Nicolas vous allez répondre dans
dans un instant parceon on va se
retrouver dans un instant et je voudrais
redire vraiment l'attachement qu'on a
aux professeurs dans dans tespmp aux
instituteurs à tout le corps enseignant
qui sont pour moi la base d'un pays et
c'est comme c'est le thé de tobleron
voilà merci non non mais c'est vrai
c'est important que je dise dans mes
mots non non mais vraiment alors on
parlait de ce professeur donc qui avait
sorti un couteau en classe qui navait
pas menacé un des élèves hein non il
leur a fait peur quand même mais les
premiers élèves auditionnés n'ont pas
décelé de menace et donc il y avait une
question de Pascal de la Tour duupain a
Azim euh B voilà la question était très
longue donc je je ne sais plus ce que
c'était mais c'était quoi je disais sur
depuis quand ouis exact voilà depuis qu
résumé non mais depu l'autorité des
professeurs a-t-elle été remise en
question par les élèves et B foué B foué
ça va faire longtemps depuis le tournant
libéral de 93 euh nous en parlons dans
dans le livre d'ailleurs au passage ce
tournant libéral ça a été le moment où
on s'est mis à s'intéresser à d'autres
métiers que les métiers régaliens les
métiers les plus importants pour une
société que sont la santé
l'école la police la justice ce genre de
chose et petit à petit on s'est mis à
faire décrocher les salaires des
enseignants ils ont vraiment il se son
fondra 45 % de baisse en 40 ans et le
respect qui leur été dû a pris le même
chemin c'estd que moi on est payé moins
on est respecté c'est une société
d'argent on est dans une société
capitaliste c'est logique et donc on est
plus respecté parce qu'on est mal payé
on a des élèves qui nous disent de toute
façon tu es mal payé ah ou c'est
insortable vous êtes passé ENIC de 2,3
dans les 2,3 1,2 1,2 là ça c'est un peu
amélifin c'est presque la moitié en
moins par rapport au coût de la vie et
ça dit tout de la considération qu'on a
pour les pour les enseignants alors que
les enseignants ils sont les premiers
témoins de tous les mots de la société
mais ça doit pas être ça doit pas être
la seule explication parce que les
élèves par exemple ils sont pas vraiment
conscients de de des salaires de leurs
professeurs donc est-ce que c'est
vraiment il y a c'est la seule raison il
doit avoir aussi d'autres d'autres
raisons pour de cette évolution vers le
vers le négatif oui clairement c'est
parce que le le savoir n'est plus au
centre justement de ce que fait l'école
mais vous avez parfaitement raison autre
chose qu'on développe beaucoup en gros
il y a un mouvement qu'on appelle le
pédagogisme pour aller vite qui a surgi
dans les années 60 70 et qui est parti
du principe que les élèves devaient
s'amuser ouais apprendre par cœur c'est
méchant la chronologie c'est du sadisme
une dicté c'est cruel mettre une
mauvaise note c'est cruel voà
not mon fil je dis à chaque fois tu
travailles bien les C dis pas bah je dis
je sais pour toi tu es une
brelle non mais non mais c'est vrai que
non il il y a des il y a des notes mais
voilà c'est plutôt maintenant c'est
desations des couleurs exactement
compéces c'est ça en fait quand ça c'est
quand vous êtes dans le vert c'est
magnifique vous êes dans le rouge ouis
c'est ça der fois j'ai vu le but mon F
j'ai vu beaucoup de
rouge pas bon pas bon il y a vert clair
et vert foncé vert foncé orange ouais
ouais il a un vert clair nu incroybl ça
ouis je sais bah là il faut pas être
daltonien sinon tu vois le bultin de ton
fils tu comprends rien mais je te dis en
tout cas compter qu'on nous incite à
surnoter les élèves régulièrement que ce
soit brevet au bac que ce sont plus des
diplômes nationaux demand à ce qu' rev
nation
tout c'est une c'est rapide on peut pas
aller plus loin mais il y a plein de
raisons qui expliquent ce décrochage
merci Nicolas d'avoir été avec nous on
on adore quand vous venez nous voir
franchement c'est un bonheur absolu et
on embrasse et en fait on voilà un gros
big up à tous les professeurs tous les
enseignants qui nous regardent et tous
les élèves il faut qu'il soi derrière
leurs professeurs les
élèves et je le redis faut que les
élèves soient avec leurs professeurs ils
nont pas contre leurs professeurs
vraiment je vous le dis c'est c'est
c'est un métier exceptionnel bravo en
tout cas merci